greetings to my 3abn family and welcome
to another 3abn today Bible Q&A my name
is Ricky Carter and I'll be your host
well we've got another hour packed
program of the questions that you guys
have sent in and you know what we've got
the answers found in God's word and our
panel who I'm going to getting ready to
introduce you to will be sharing with us
those answers so let me introduce to my
right we have brother John densey
welcome brother John thank you I'm glad
to be here it's been a blessing to look
over these questions study and ask the
Lord for answers from his word and the
Lord blesses you know it's it's a
fantastic learning experience to study
God's word amen amen and next to his
right we have from via Skype we have
Pastor James rafy welcome brother Pastor
James good to be here Ricky and John
glad to join you for this Q&A I love
this program it's such a blessing and a
privilege to be able to answer people's
questions from the word of God amen amen
well before we get into the word of God
it's always best that we start off with
a word of prayer asking for the holy
spirit's guidance so brother John could
you lead us in prayer please sure thanks
let's go to the Lord in prayer Our
loving Heavenly Father we come before
your throne of grace in the name of
Jesus we ask for your blessing as we
share from your word we pray for your
Holy Spirit to give us the words to
speak
and we pray that this program will
create an interest in your children all
over the world to study the holy
scriptures we pray that this program
will be a blessing in such a way that uh
the message of Hope will spark in their
heart a desire to share God's word with
others we thank you for 3abn and the
possibility of reaching people with your
message we ask you in Jesus name amen
amen amen
before we get started with our questions
I want to remind our let our viewers
know how they can participate with our
Bible Q&A program you can send in your
questions via email to Bible QA 3ab
bn. that's Bible qa3
bn.trek
3975 and then the third way you can
participate those of you who are on
Instagram you can send us your questions
at
3abn official that's at
3abn official and also have you heard
about 3abn Bible anwers.com well on this
website you can get a lot of your Bible
questions answered there are answers to
questions pertaining to the second
coming of Christ answers to questions to
what happens when you die and and even
answers to questions on which day is the
biblical Sabbath so check out that
website 3abn Bible anwers.com all right
well Pastor rafy I've got your first
question you ready yes I'm ready all
right can you please help me understand
what the spirit of Prophecy is that was
sent to us from a viewer Sherry in
Arizona and she sent that to us via
email that's a great question uh from
Sher in Arizona the spirit of Prophecy
according to the Bible is one of the
gifts that God has given to his church
in both the Old and the New Testament
and this gift is identified as such in
verses like Ephesians 4: 11 this is what
it says in Ephesians 4:1 in fact let's
just look at the context of Ephesians
chapter 4 it says beginning with verse
11 and he gave that is God gave some
Apostles and some prophets and some
evangelists and some pastors and
teachers what for verse 12 for the
perfecting of the Saints for the work of
the ministry for the edifying of the
body of Christ for how long were these
gifts given verse 13 till we all come in
the unity of the faith and of the
knowledge of the Son of God unto a
perfect man unto the measure of the
stature of the fullness of Christ why
verse 14 that we henceforth be no more
children tossed to fro and carried about
with every wind of Doctrine by the
slight of men and cunning craftiness
whereby they lie in wait to
deceive but verse 15 speaking the truth
in love may grow up unto him in all
things which is the head even Christ so
here's where we find the gift of
Prophecy or the spirit of Prophecy that
is given to the church it's a gift given
by the Holy Spirit given by God for the
edifying of the church so the church
could come into full Unity so the church
would not be deceived by the cunning
craftiness of men until the fullness of
Christ is revealed in the church that is
until the very end of time when Christ's
character is fully perfected among his
peop amen the gift of Prophecy is an
identifying Mark of God's Endtime
Remnant church as noted in Revelation 12
and verse 17 where God shows a church
who is the remnant of the seed of the
woman that keeps the Commandments of God
and has the testimony excuse me the
spirit of Prophecy the testimony of
Jesus and in Revelation chapter 19:10
we're told that the testimony of Jesus
is the spirit of Prophecy and again in
First Corinthians 12: 7-10 we see the
same gift given by the Holy Spirit to
the church as the holy spirit will
sometimes we see this gift manifested in
certain times and occasions in the
church and there other times we don't
see this gift manifested we as 7-Day
Adventist believe that this gift of
Prophecy was given to the remnant Church
God's Remnant Church by God and was
revealed through the ministry of Ellen G
white who meets the biblical
characteristics of a prophet amen by
manifesting the gift of Prophecy for the
guidance of God's people in these last
days what Seven Day Adventist do not
believe at least not officially though
there may be some people who go take
this a little bit further than our
official position that is that Ellen
White is equal to the Bible we do not
believe that we believe that Ellen White
is just as inspired as Bible writers we
believe her writings though are the
Lesser light leading to the greater
light of the Bible amen so we take the
Bible and the Bible only as our
Authority and for our beliefs and for
our doctrines but we understand the gift
of the spirit of Prophecy manifest
through Ellen White is this lesser light
just as inspired as the greater light to
help us to better understand the word of
God which lays the foundation for our
Authority and for our doctrines and for
our teachings so hopefully this clears
up the question that you asked about
understanding what the spirit of
Prophecy is it's a gift that's given by
the holy spirit manifested in the church
through the old and the New Testament
through prophets who spoke inspired by
God to give direction light to God's
people we see that gift manifested in
God's Remnant Church in the end of time
through the ministry of Ellen White who
is not equal to the Bible but is just as
inspired as the Bible and is that lesser
light leading to the greater light of
the word of God amen amen thank you
Pastor
raffy all right brother John I've got
your first
question in Matthew chap
2:1 why did the wise men come bearing
these particular Gifts of frankincense
myrr and gold that was sent to us from
Michael in Michigan who emailed that to
us thank you uh thank you Michael for
your question and that is a good
question actually this is something that
many people have wondered about uh
Scholars have tried to bring in
different interpretations of this the
Bible doesn't really specify there's no
verse in particular that states this is
why and I also want to me mention that
sometimes people think there were three
of them because there are three gifts
but the Bible doesn't say there were
just three of them
they mentioned they brought gold
frankincense and Merr it's interesting
uh that as we look in Isaiah chapter 60:
6 notice this the multitude of camels
shall cover your land the the dramedies
of Midian and epha all those from Shiva
shall come they shall bring gold and
incense and they shall proclaim the
Praises of the lord we can conclude from
this verse that they were bringing in
sends gifts to offer praise to God now
remember that they came saying where is
he that is
born king of Israel so in actuality uh
you look at history and you find out
that in ancient times these were among
the gifts offered to Kings these were
among the gifts also offered to deities
of course there's only one God but the
Pagan World looked at their uh man made
gods or even objects in nature as gods
and they
brought gold frankincense and myr to
these deities on but there is only one
God this is what the Bible says and this
is what really is the fact so I would
like to also mention that these three
items are found in the description of
what God Said to build me a sanctuary
all three of these items are placed
there let's take a look at some of them
in Leviticus chapter 2 verse one it says
when any will offer a meat offering unto
the Lord his offering shall be of fine
flow he shall pour oil upon it and put
frankincense there on yeah actually I
mentioned earlier Isaiah 60:6 the word
incense there is actually a word for
frankincense when you look at
frankincense and
myrr um they they are both they as far
as the oil is concerned they both have
healing properties and also I have
recently heard that frankincense can be
used to help people that are having pain
even AR uh arthritic pain AR arthritis
pain uh so anyway our uh frankincense
frankincense is also found in Exodus
30:34 it says and the Lord said unto
Moses take unto the sweet spices stati
and anuka and galbanum these sweet
spices with pure frankincense of each
shall there be a like weight and thou
shal make it a perfume a confection
after the art of the Apothecary tempered
tempered with uh together pure and holy
so there's a perfume made with
frankincense that was part of the
sanctuary service also the bread on top
of the showbread was sprinkled with
frankincense as an offering to the Lord
let's look at myr really quick in Exodus
chapter 30 verse 22 uh it says moreover
verse 22 and onward moreover the Lord
spake unto Moses saying take thou also
unto thee three principal spices pure
myrrh 500 shekels and of sweet cinnamon
half so much even 250 shekels and of a
sweet calamus 250 shekels and of aazia
500 shekels after the shekele of the
sanctuary and uh an oil and of olive oil
and hen and thou shalt make it an holy
an uh holy ointment anointment compound
after the art of the Apothecary it shall
be a holy anointing oil in this was
included
myrr uh also we have uh in the Song of
Solomon um it says
here at verse 12 and 13 his eyes are as
the eyes of doves by the rivers of
waters washed with milk and fitly set
his cheeks are as bed of spices as sweet
flowers his lips like lies dropping
sweet smelling myrr so Myrrh is a sweet
smelling uh item I see the time has run
out gold when we look at gold it's also
in the sanctuary the The Arc of the
testimony was covered with pure gold we
also have the um the um the The Mercy
Seat was made with pure gold you also
have the uh the Candlestick made of pure
gold but also when you look at the gifts
brought to Jesus you have an interesting
thing is because pure gold had great
value it could also be an offer of a
gift to provide for them economic means
for his uh daily needs amen amen thank
you very much brother John okay all
right Pastor rafid here's your second
question regarding the seven trumpets in
Revelation are there going to be are
they going to be physical sounds also
are some events going to happen after
the trumpets already passed that was
emailed to
us great question the seven trumpets of
Revelation are a challenging subject
probably one of the most difficult
subjects in the Book of Revelation they
cover chapters 8 through 11 and they are
symbolic uh seven actually symbolizes
complete or perfect according to Genesis
chap 2 1-3 where God completes his work
on the seventh day and rests and blesses
his sanctifies the seventh day and then
uh the trumpets uh really cover the
complete history of time from John's day
to the very end of time uh a trumpet
actually symbolizes many things in the
Bible a trumpet can symbolize judgment a
trumpet can symbolize warning and alarm
uh the day of atonement is symbolized by
a trumpet and a call to preparation for
battle is used uh to symbolize by a
trumpet let me just share a few Bible
verses with you on this uh Joel chap 2
vers1 says blow the trumpet in Zion
sound an alarm in my Holy Mountain let
all the inhabitants of the Earth or the
land tremble for the day of the Lord is
coming for it is at hand that's Joel 2:1
so here a trumpet symbolizes alarm then
we also have Leviticus 23: 23 to 27 it
says then the Lord spoke to Moses saying
speak to the children of Israel saying
in the seventh month of the and on the
first day of the month you shall have a
Sabbath rest a memorial of the blowing
of the trumpets a holy convocation you
shall do no customary work in it you
shall offer an offering made by fire to
the Lord and the Lord spake to Moses
saying and also on the 10th day of the
seventh month shall be the day of
atonement it shall be a holy convocation
for you you shall affix your souls and
uh offer an offering made by fire to the
Lord so you have the trumpets blowing in
preparation for the day of atonement you
have the trumpets blowing in sound of
alarm Paul talks about this in 1
Corinthians 14:8 you know if the trumpet
gives an uncertain sound who will
prepare himself for the battle and of
course you've got Zephaniah 1 verse6 we
won't read all these but I'll just give
you the references Jeremiah 45 8 Joshua
1-23 and even Revelation
1:10 Likens a trumpet to the voice of
Christ his voice was like a trumpet the
son of man the voice of the son of man
was like a trumpet that's verses 10 and
13 of Revelation chapter 1 so the
trumpets are not physical sounds per se
in Revelation the trumpets are symbolic
uh they're symbolic of warnings of
judgments they're symbolic of a call to
the day of atonement uh they call us to
prepare for the day of the Lord amen for
planet Earth to get ready for the second
coming and they've been blowing
throughout the Christian error from
John's time all the way down to the end
of time we could say the first trumpet
was the sound of warning concerning
Jerusalem and the destruction of
Jerusalem which Christ predicted would
take place within a generation of time
from his death and resurrection and it
did it took place in ad70 uh just under
SE 40 years from the time that Christ
died and was resurrected and uh many in
fact most of the judgments or Warnings
or alarms of the seven trumpets are
historical they are already passed uh
you asked the question about they are
they in the past or in the present they
are pasted though we can see that some
of the principles found in these
historical accounts may be repeated for
example the millerite movement is part
of the seven trumpets history prophetic
history in Revelation chap 10 uh it's
part of that seventh trumpet past
history yet God's people still
experience uh Sweet Bitter experiences
when it comes to the word of God you
know the John was uh told to eat this
little book The Book of Daniel the
prophetic Book of Daniel and when he ate
it it was sweet in his mouth sweet to
The Taste but it was bitter in its
stomach and it symbolized the millerite
experience a sweet experience with a
bitter disappointment because the
millerites misunderstood what the
sanctuary was similarly the early
disciples misunderstood Messiah and his
ministry and that he was to be crucified
and not reign as conqueror of the
Gentiles and so they were very
disappoint appointed when Christ was
crucified the millerites were very
disappointed when Jesus didn't come as
they supposed to cleanse the sanctuary
I.E the Earth uh but actually move from
the holy place to the most holy place in
1844 we look at the last trumpet we know
that that trumpet is announcing the end
of the things of this Earth the kingdoms
of this world and the final
establishment of God's Everlasting
Kingdom so we still have a trumpet to
sound we're still in the sounding of the
seventh trumpet moving down through
history so all of those trumpets
historically prophetically are past
though in principle some of those
experiences may be repeated and then we
have of course the final trumpet and
we're there in uh listening for the
sound of that seventh trumpet and the
second coming of Jesus Christ amen amen
thank you Pastor raffy all right brother
John here I've got your second
question why did Noah build an altar and
offering and offer burnt offerings in
Genesis 8:20 that was sent to us from
Adam from Alaska and he emailed that
question to us thank you uh we have in
the
scriptures people like Abraham Noah you
you see wherever they went they built an
altar to worship God the interesting
thing also here is uh you mentioned uh
Genesis 820 I'm going to go ahead and
read from Genesis 8:20 to verse 22 then
Noah built an altar to the Lord and took
of every clean animal and every clean
bird and offer burnt offerings
onto I'm sorry on the Altar and the Lord
smelled a soothing Aroma then the Lord
said in his heart I will never again
curse the ground for man's sake although
the imagination of a man's heart is evil
from his youth nor will I again destroy
every living thing as I have done while
the Earth remains seed time and harvest
cold and heat winter and summer and day
and night shall not cease remember that
they were in the ark approximately if
you calculate the times from the time
they went in about
370 days and from that time that they
went into the ark no sacrifices were
made no uh sweet smelling Aroma went up
to heaven because they were inside the
ark it was not appropriate of course
they surely sang and praised God and
prayed but an actual sacrifice was not
made that reminded the Believers of the
sacrifice of Jesus Christ this was the
first opportunity to do so remembering
that God would sent his son to die for
us and uh and through that sacrifice the
whole human race would have the
opportunity for salvation why did they
do this because they wanted to worship
God there's no clear scripture that says
why but look at the uh what happens
after this we continue now in Genesis
chapter 9 vers uh I'll start with verse
one and I'll just mention a few verses
it says so God blessed Noah and his sons
and said to them be fruitful and
multiply and fill the Earth
uh let's go to verse six it says uh
whoever sheds man's blood by man his
blood shall be shed for in the image of
God he made it he made man and as for
you be fruitful and multiply bring forth
abundantly in the earth and multiply it
and God made a covenant with Noah and
his family and with the human race and
with the animals and notice what happens
there in verse 11 thus I I establish my
Covenant with you never again shall All
Flesh be cut off By the Waters of the
flood never again shall there be a flood
to destroy the Earth and God said this
is the sign of the Covenant which I make
between me and you and every living
creature that is with you for Perpetual
Generations I set my rainbow in the
cloud and it shall be a sign shall be
for the sign of the Covenant between me
and the Earth and it shall be when I
bring a cloud over the Earth that the
rainbow shall be seen in the cloud and I
will remember my Covenant which is
between me and you and every living
creature of All Flesh the water shall
never again become a flood to destroy
all flesh so we have god making this
Covenant with uh the whole creation uh
saying that he will not destroy the
Earth the offering in the offerings of
the altars uh precipitated this
declaration by God and now I bring to
you the example that Noah brought to us
God protected them in the ARK for 370
years the waters were upon the Earth for
a long period of time God protected them
provided for them and now in gratitude
for this they are doing this offering
amen and uh this is the example for us
when we see that God has been merciful
to us and has provided for us we should
take time to thank him we no longer need
to offer animals but we should stop and
thank him praise His name in song and
thank him for his Mercy amen amen thank
you brother thank
you well Pastor rafid before I give you
your next question I want to remind our
viewers at home how they can participate
you can participate in one of three ways
you can email your questions to Bible
Bible QA 3bn dotv that's Bible qa3
bn.trek 75 that's 618 228
3975 and for those of you who want to
use Instagram you can send us your
questions that way at
3bn official that's at 3bn
official all right Pastor James here's
your third
question will there be ranks Among Us in
heaven when we go there if yes will it
not lead to
Rebellion that's from Briston in Malawi
who emailed that
question all right Briston that's a good
question will there be ranks in heaven
and if so won't it lead to Rebellion
Among Us yes there will be ranks in
heaven meaning that there will be those
who are in Greater positions and others
who are in less positions of
responsibility of uh ability of
understanding of knowledge of physical
maturity and wisdom and experience and
Duty that's the way Heaven is set up
right now now and we have no reason to
believe that it's going to change in the
future because we're all in different
places in our own growth and
experience and even God and the angels
are set up in a certain Rank and order
so but the Bible tells us that
Affliction will not rise up a second
time Nam chap 1:3 so this will not lead
to rebellion and it did lead to
Rebellion at one point because Lucifer
got jealous of Christ got jealous of the
fact that Christ was next to God was one
with God was taken into the counsel of
God because of course he was God and
Lucifer felt that he should have that
position and that Authority and that
rank if you will but we got we need to
recognize what the Bible actually
teaches about God and about God's
character because Lucifer has actually
misrepresented or even we should could
say misunderstood God the the greatest
of all according to Jesus Christ is to
be the servant of all when we get to
heaven we're told that we're going to
have this great marriage supper of the
lamb and Jesus Christ is going to serve
us as he did when he was on this Earth
at the Last Supper he actually humbled
himself and washed the disciples feet he
who is equal with God empties himself of
his own Divinity according to
Philippians chapter 2 he becomes a man
he becomes a servant he dies the death
of the Cross and this reminds us
continually that the highest in heaven
is the one who is the servant of all in
fact Jesus tells us this in uh these
words Jesus says to his disciples he
calls them unto himself and he says to
them you know that they which are
accounted to rule over the Gentiles
exercise lordship over them and their
great ones exercise Authority upon them
but so shall it not be among you but
whosoever will be great among you let
him be your minister and whosoever of
you will be chiefest let him be servant
of all for even the son of man came not
to be ministered unto but to minister
and to give his life a ransom for all
Jesus Christ didn't come just to save us
from sin and from guilt and from its
consequences Jesus Christ came to save
us from self-exaltation that was the sin
that began the rebellion in heaven the
sin of self-exaltation Jesus Christ came
to restore in us the image of God and
that image of God is an image of
humility it's an image of service it's
an image of un or other centered love
and we had lost that image we lost that
image because there was a rebellion that
is described in in Isaiah 14:
12-14 it says there how art thou fallen
from Heaven o Lucifer son of the morning
how art thou cut down to the ground
which should weaken the Nations how did
he weaken the Nations for he said in his
heart I will Ascend un Heaven I will
exalt my throne above the stars of God I
will sit also upon the Mount of the
congregation I will in the size of the
north I will Ascend above the heights of
the clouds I will be like the most high
in these verses we not only have the
rebellion of Luc but we have a
misrepresentation of the character of
God God isn't self-seeking God isn't
seeking to be to place himself high
above everyone else God is self abasing
God is other centered and Jesus Christ
came to correct this re reflection of
God's character and in doing so he is
seeking for us to to be restored to that
image of service and other centered love
so the way to heaven excuse me the way
to up is not down down is up and in
God's kingdom all of us are going to
seek to serve and to give to one another
and whatever rank we have we're going to
be content with that rank because our
highest uh love our highest desire in
heaven is going to be other centered um
selfless service to God and to others
amen amen I'm looking forward to serving
him in heaven amen amen no there's no
there's not going to be any Envy no
jealousy oh why don't I get that you
know it's it's gone it's gone it's
beautiful beautiful experience yes yes
all right brother John here's your third
question how do I help my brother if his
mind is not there that's from Anthony
who emailed that to us Anthony I want to
praise the Lord for your concern for
your brother and uh it is something that
we should all have concern for our
brothers our family members and of
course really everyone but I understand
from your question that your brother has
certain CH uh challenges understanding
things and so uh I would like to share
some scriptures with you that um I think
should be able to help uh first in
Romans
12:3 uh an interesting message is here
for us for I say through the grace given
unto me to every man that is among you
not to think of himself of more highly
than he ought to think but to think
soberly according as God hath dealt to
every man The Measure of Faith so in
some degree your brother has some
Measure of Faith amen uh may not be able
to understand everything but surely he
can understand
kindness uh love and acts of kindness so
uh if he has these type of challenges I
would say continually well I continually
often praise the Lord in his presence
amen say to him God is good isn't he
share scriptures with him amen uh
because this uh will have a wonderful
effect upon Him second Peter chapter 3:9
the Lord is not slack concerning his
promis as some count slackness but is
longsuffering toward us not willing that
any should perish but that all should
come to
repentance to some degree uh uh he may
understand when he has done wrong and
you can pray with him and help him
understand that God is love I read to
you from Jeremiah 31:3 the Lord has
appeared of old to me saying yes I have
loved you with an Everlasting Love
Therefore with loving kindness I have
drawn you so showing him love letting
him know that God wants to draw you with
his love and tell him that Jesus Christ
came to die for the whole world and he
came to die for you tell him repeat
these things to him because the mind
will will it will be recorded in the
mind and the mind adapts to whatever it
is exposed to if he's exposed to evil
things the mind will be exposed to evil
things and he will react according to
the evil things he is exposed to but if
he's exposed to loving kindness songs of
praise talking about God his mind will
adapt to that and he will react to that
notice Hosea 11:4 I drew them with
gentle cords with bands of love I was to
them as those who take the Yoke from
their neck I stooped and fed them tell
him that God created the world and he
continually shows his loving kindness to
us so I encourage you to do these things
and I know uh that this will have a
wonderful effect upon your brother again
I commend you and praise the Lord for
your desire to share with your brother
naturally we encourage you to pray for
him and there is a blessing in sharing
these things with your brother because
it also has an effect upon
you excuse me and as you do this you
will notice that uh his countenance May
will be brighter and he will have a more
more cheerful attitude this is uh what I
suggest and I encourage you to uh put
these into practice and good things will
happen amen amen thank you brother John
okay Pastor James I've got your fourth
question here it
is can you please explain what in quotes
the Sabbath was made for man not man for
the Sabbath what that means and that was
from Diane who sent that to us from
Jamaica on Instagram
thank you Diane appreciate that question
and yes let's begin with the first part
of the statement uh the Sabbath was made
for man and not man for the Sabbath so
in the
context uh we need to understand what's
going on Jesus when he says the Sabbath
was made for man is actually refuting a
criticism of the Pharisees the Pharisees
are accusing uh the disciples are
breaking the Sabbath because they were
picking and eating corn on their way
through a field
uh to satisfy their hunger they were
hungry it was the Sabbath day they were
hungry they started picking the grains
of the Corn and eating the grains of the
Corn and the FES picked up on this and
began to criticize uh Christ they didn't
go to the disciples they went to Christ
that's an earmark of someone who is
critical and judgmental they don't
address the person at fault but they go
to somebody else and accuse
secondhand uh this and so Christ is
responding to this criticism of his
disciples who are satisfying their
hunger and of course the Sabbath does
prohibit secular work uh on the Sabbath
day the seventh day uh Saturday uh
because God designed the Sabbath to be a
a mini vacation if you will a cation
from secular work an oasis in the middle
of the week uh a time to resk physically
to rest physically to mentally recharge
to spiritually recharge so in this sense
uh the Sabbath wasn't just made for one
particular group of people the Sabbath
wasn't just made for the Jewish Nation
uh in this sense in the fullest meaning
of Sabbath rest the Sabbath Was Made For
All Mankind amen uh not just for one
specific uh the benefit of one specific
group of people because God is Not
partial God loves the entire world in
fact in the Old Testament you find in
Isaiah 56 that God is very clear that
those he gave the Sabbath to the Jewish
Nation to share with the world and he
said anyone in the world any Gentile in
the world that Embraces the Sabbath and
takes a hold of God's covenant which is
uh connected with the Sabbath uh that
they too can receive the blessing of the
Sabbath the blessing of this Oasis of
rest and recharge spiritual recharge in
the midst of each week so we could say
that the Sabbath was given to the Jewish
Nation as a way for God to preserve its
meaningful rest and worship for all men
mankind he he he gave it to the Jewish
Nation as a responsible depository of
entrusted Goods to share with the world
Amen and but we cannot say as Jesus
makes it clear in this uh next part of
the text that God made the Jews for the
Sabbath that God made the Jewish Nation
for the Sabbath that the Sabbath was
only for the Jewish Nation because Jesus
makes it very clear the Sabbath was made
for man that is For All Mankind and not
man that is a certain group of people
for the Sabbath right and of course that
makes sense if the Sabbath is a blessing
if the Sabbath is to be a day of rest
and a day of spiritual recharge a day of
worship a day to remember our creator it
it makes sense because God is the
creator of everyone not just of a
certain group of people God created All
Mankind and not just one specific group
of mankind and God wants us to know him
as Creator to worship him and to rest in
him and to get recharged and to receive
the benefits of the Sabbath he wants
everyone to experience that not just one
specific group of people amen so we know
this um because in the context of
Christ's life and death Jesus Christ
actually as our example kept the Sabbath
when he was alive and even kept the
Sabbath in his death Jesus could have
rose right after he died on Friday on
the preparation day he could have Rose
the next day on Sabbath but he rested
the tomb on Sabbath we know this from
Reading Luke chapter 23 the last part of
that chapter then verse chapter 24:1
that Christ died on the preparation day
Friday rested in the Tomb on Sabbath and
resurrected on the first day of the
week's Sunday so Jesus kept the Sabbath
in his life Jesus kept the Sabbath in
his death because Jesus is the savior of
all mankind and he wants all of us to be
uh to be recipients of the blessing of
Sabbath rest amen amen amen thank you
brother thank you okay brother John
here's your fourth
question why is Jesus name not Emmanuel
Isaiah 7:14 and Matthew
1:23 both say it should be Emmanuel
Emanuel meaning God With Us however the
name Jesus means savior it's not the
same name nor does it have the same
meaning please explain and that's from
Renee in Detroit who texted that to us
thank you Renee uh this is a very good
question uh you will not find the name
Emmanuel mentioned again uh in the New
Testament after it is mentioned in the
Book of Matthew chapter 1 and that's a
uh a good question why is his name not
called I would like to make a suggestion
in this uh Jesus was severely criticized
and uh mocked and Etc by the scribes and
Sadducees Pharisees and the elders and
the priests
uh to go around and say what's your name
my name is Emanuel god with oh so you're
God With Us remember that as you look
especially into John chapter 8 he was
attacked they sent spies after him if he
if this name was used it would have been
I may say worse for him than it was but
let's go look at these verses because
this is an interesting way it is
expressed in Matthew chapter 1
beginning in verse 20 but while he
thought about these things behold an
angel of the Lord appeared to him in a
dream saying Joseph son of David do not
be afraid to take to you marry your wife
for that which is conceived in her is of
the Holy Spirit and she will bring forth
a son and notice and you shall call his
name Jesus for he will save his people
from their sins so he was specifically
told you shall call his name Jesus for
will save his people from their sins
let's continue so all this was done that
it might be fulfilled which was spoken
by the Lord through the prophet saying
behold the Virgin shall be with child
and bear a son and now notice and they
shall call his name Emmanuel which is
translated God With Us question who is
this day that will call his name Emanuel
which is translated god with us and then
Joseph uh being uh aroused from sleep
did as the angel of the Lord commanded
and him and took uh to him his wife and
so uh verse 25 and did not know her till
she had brought forth forth her
firstborn son and he called his name
Jesus Jesus so he did as the angel
instructed him but who is this day I
will say to you that it's not the
scribes and Pharisees Sadducees uh the
chief priests and the elders they did
not call Jesus
Emmanuel because this is not the the day
is those that are his Believers but not
necessarily using the name by by their
expression they're saying you are God
you are with us notice here in uh let's
begin
in John chapter 1 I have to skip here
some verses because of time John chapter
1 verse 1 2 and 3 here's John in the
beginning was the word and the Word was
with God and the Word was God and he was
in the beginning with God all things
were made through him and without him
was not any anything made that was made
so uh we see here that John is calling
him that he is God and so we we see this
reference now if you continue reading in
John chapter 1 uh boy time is really
moving quickly here uh let me let me go
down yeah John chapter 1 verse 43 the
following day Jesus wanted to go to
Galilee and he found philli and said to
him follow me now Philip was from beta
the city of Andrew and Peter Philip
found Nathaniel and said to him we have
found him of whom Moses in the law and
also the prophets wrote Jesus of
Nazareth the son of Joseph and Nathaniel
said to him can anything good come out
of Nazareth Philip said to him come and
see Jesus saw Nathaniel coming toward
him and said of him behold an Israelite
indeed in whom is no deceit Nathaniel
said to him how do you know me Jesus
answered and said to him Phillip before
Phillip called you when you were were
under the Fig Tre I saw you Nathaniel
answered and said to him Rabbi you are
the Son of God you are the king of
Israel so we see evidence of his
followers saying you are the Son of God
and be God With Us you are the Son of
God we have other instances for example
you have uh Thomas eventually after he
appeared to him he's Thomas uh after
Jesus appeared because he has said hey
I'm not going to believe till I see the
nails in his hand the print of the nails
in his hands and and when Jesus appeared
he said to uh he said to him s here I am
basically and Thomas answered it
answered and said my Lord and my God so
he's in essence saying you're God you're
here with us so there are other a few
others that I could point out but this
is uh they that they were his followers
amen amen thank you sir thank you all
right Pastor rafid here's
your fifth and final question can man
judge God I've heard people say that if
God doesn't come back soon then he will
have to apologize to Sodom and gomorah
to me that statement sounds like judging
that's from tamy in Kansas who texted
that to
us thank you Tammy in Kansas that's a
very important question and no not in
the sense that you are talking about
here Tammy uh we are warned to stay away
from these kinds of witty statements
that misuse the Bible and misrepresent
God
uh Romans chapter 3 though does tell us
that men actually judge God in Romans
chap 3: 3-4 what if some did not believe
will their unbelief make the
faithfulness of God without effect
question mark certainly not exclamation
mark indeed it goes on to say let God be
true and every man a liar as it is
written that you may be justified in
your words and may overcome when you are
judged so clearly we see here in the
Bible that God is being judged he's
judged all the time men and women judge
God when they question him they question
his character they questions
faithfulness uh they question how he's
dealing with sin and salvation and of
course this is just part of the process
of the Judgment we see this again in
Revelation 11 and verse one John is
given a read like under a measuring rod
and the angel that stands by tells him
to rise and measure the temple of God
The Altar and those who worship there so
there are three elements here that are
being judged or measured and that word
measure means to judge uh the temple of
God that's where God dwells that is his
government his character how he deals
with us with sin with the sin problem
and then the altar that represents the
sacrifice of Christ specifically the
cross and Calvary and then those who
worship we human beings are actually
judged in how we respond to the
sacrifice of Jesus on Calvary and to
God's character of love and the way that
he's dealt with the sin problem and so
we see that judgment uh uh exploding out
in proclamation in Revelation 14: 6 and
7 John sees another Angel flying in the
midst of Heaven having the Everlasting
gospel the good news to preach to those
who dwell on the earth to Every Nation
tribe tongue and people saying with a
loud voice fear God give glory to him
here it is for the hour of his judgment
has come and worship him that made
Heaven and Earth and the Seas and The
Fountains of waters worship him that
made Heaven and Earth and the Seas of
The Fountains of waters is a call of
course to the Sabbath which we just
talked about and I wanted to mention um
well no let's not just go there and
let's stick here so the hour of his
judgment is also a declaration of what's
taking place on planet Earth there is a
judgment hour that we are called into as
human beings we are going to be judged
in relationship to God and our uh
response to his love and his sacrifice
but God has also judged uh his character
and the way that he's relating to us and
to sin and the whole sin problem is on
trial if you will God is in this with us
and we see this uh some uh confirmed in
the story of Luke 7 the woman in the
alabaster box um let's just read a few
of those verses vers 36 through 39 and
we'll get a big picture here of what's
taking place in relation to God and and
us and the Judgment so one of the
Pharisees asked him to eat with him and
he Jesus went to the Pharisees house and
sat down to eat and behold a certain
woman in the city who was a sinner when
she knew that Jesus sat at the table in
the Pharisees house brought an alabaster
flax of fragrant oil and stood At His
Feet behind him weeping and she began to
wash his feet with the tears and wipe
them with the hair of her head and she
kissed his feet and anointed them with
fragrant oil now when the Pharisee had
invited him saw all this he spoke to
himself saying this man if he were or
Prophet would know what manner of woman
who is touching him would know who and
what manner of woman this is who is
touching him for she is a sinner so you
see here in this story God Christ is
implicated with the woman we could say
the church with this woman uh she's a
sinner but he is questioned also what
kind of man is this he should know if he
was a prophet he would know what kind of
woman this is God's grace and God's
mercy in saving us are also being
questioned or Jud judged in the Judgment
hour how can you save those Sinners even
Lucifer says they can't replace me
they've sinned just like I have how can
you put them in heaven and kick me out
of heaven so the Judgment involves both
God and us and just the simplest answer
to the question is yes uh we are God is
being judged but we cannot judge God by
making statements uh like the one you
mentioned um that is uh
mischaracterizing God God and misusing
His word amen thank you Pastor raffy all
right brother John here's your last
question can you please explain what
acts chap 10: 11-15 really means and
that's from Miriam in Papua Nini okay
Miriam let's go ahead and read Acts
chapter 10 beginning in verse 9 actually
the next day as they went on their
journey and Drew near the city Peter
went up on the housetop to pray about
the sixth hour then he became very
hungry and wanted to eat but while they
made ready he fell to a trance that
means he's he was seeing a vision and
saw heaven open and an object like a
great sheep bound at the Four Corners
descending to him and L down to the
Earth in it were all kinds of
four-footed animals of the earth wild
beasts creeping things and birds of the
air and a voice came to him rise Peter
kill and eat but Peter said not so Lord
for I have never eaten anything common
or unclean and they both a voice spoke
to him again again the second time what
God has cleansed you must not call
common so what's going on here these
animals that are unclean are those
animals that eat the dying and decaying
things basically they're the garbage
collectors and waste uh cleaners of the
earth let's move quickly now to acts 10:
24 what does this mean it is cleared up
in these verses and the following day
they entered cesaria now Cornelius was
waiting for them and had called to
gather his relatives and close friends
as Peter was coming in Cornelius met him
and fell down at his feet and worshiped
him but Peter lifted him up saying stand
up I myself am also a man and as he
talked with him he went in and found
many who had come together then he said
to them you know how unlawful it is for
a Jewish man to keep company with or go
to one of another Nation but God has
shown me that is in the vision he saw uh
that I should not call any man common or
unclean what he saw in the vision Peter
understood God is telling him you should
not call any man unclean and this was a
practice of the Jews to call those that
were not Jews unclean so this is really
what it means and uh we we encourage you
to continue studying and look at the uh
the whole context and you'll see that
this is what the Bible says amen wow
time went by fast well we're going to
take a a short break and you're going to
see on the screen how you can
participate with 3bn today Bible Q&A so
don't go away we'll be right
back if you're enjoying our 3abn Bible
Q&A then tell your friends each Monday
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's holy word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand to have your questions
answered on a future program just email
them to us at Bible qa3 3ab bn. that's
Bible qa@ 3abn.org
[Music]
yeah I just wanted to share we mentioned
in one of the questions uh will there be
ranks among Among Us uh some verses from
Jesus and I didn't give the reference
for those verses so those reference that
references Mark chap 10 veres 42 to 45
where Jesus talks about those who are
the greatest or those who are ministers
and servants Among Us amen amen and I
would like to say concerning the what
Peter was shown in the vision some
people look at this and say oh we can
eat anything now uh
the Constitution the physical aspects of
these animals have not changed they are
still animals that are not safe to eat
if you eat these animals such as pork
such as shrimp and lobster you have a
greater risk of getting sick or being
weakened to get sick so please
understand that it stands as a still a a
message for God's people to leave these
unclean animals alone don't eat them
because you are at risk of getting sick
they're not uh animals look at look at
the what they do they eat all the junk
all the stuff that's dying and uh you
are taking this stuff in greater risk
for getting sick so in Acts chapter 10 I
go back to that and and it says that
Peter said God has shown me how did he
show him in the vision that I should not
call any man common or a clean this is
the reason for the vision not to give
you permission to eat whatever uh is out
there uh that uh could be dangerous to
your health amen amen well thank you
gentlemen thank you for your time and
for the answers that we found here in
God's word and thank you thank you for
joining us before we go I want to leave
you with this fun Short scripture song
from Proverbs
30:5 every word of God is
pure every word of God is
pure he is a shield to those who put
their trust in him God
[Music]
bless